check out our sponsors nature's blends
they specialize in premium ethiopian
black seed products
their products are fantastic health
supplements and also from the sunnah
the website is in the description link
below you can also use a discount code
salam 10 for 10 of their products
assalamu alaikum i'm telling you about
okay two brothers and sisters
and dear friends just a quick video and
just a little reminder as well
whenever you go and buy any product yeah
whatever it may be
as a muslim be very careful because
just about 10 minutes ago i didn't drink
alcohol i actually ate
alcohol yes how did it happen well
i've heard a lot about truffles now i'm
not mistaken truffles
are something that comes out the ground
all right unless i'm confusing that with
something else it's what push people eat
so i went to an organic shop because i
like to eat well if there's anything
that i do in my life
if i was a millionaire i'll just treat
myself to organic food i just
like to eat good yeah so i saw this for
10 pounds quite expensive but i thought
i just want to try it just the
experience
so i looked at that and i thought okay
espresso it says espresso wild
hip welding berry wild raspberry
hazelnut hazel hazel hazelnut nugget oh
sorry the one at the top is a different
language
i'm trying to okay wild raspberry
hazelnut hazelnut nugget and espresso
so i quickly went through the
ingredients just organic
chocolate truffles and it says
assortment you know just read through
it's like okay all right i'll get
dressed here
so i got this i came home and opened it
so i was telling
my wife you know what look we want to
try this man this looks like some
painting there's a little chunk in there
and i opened it and i thought yes yes
blood
yes you know we can watch maybe some
airtel and
have these so obviously i'm a raspberry
farm fan
raspberry yes i'll correct i pronounce
that right so i took one of this
all right i bit well i put in my mouth
and i was like
okay raspberry fell nice i chewed into
it
and there was a breakdown of some kind
of liquid i don't know it's not
creamy it tastes something it's not bad
so as i'm eating it obviously i'm
swallowing it and
i can feel like some kind of burn in the
back and i think it usually
like in my head i'm i'm just thinking
okay that's usually when you have like
ginger it's usually when you have like
ginger and i thought subhanallah like
i've never i've never drank alcohol in
the context of like
drink drink i've tried it like i just
thought okay yeah like back in there
uh nothing to be proud of i'm just
saying it because of the whole incident
and i thought nah this
this tastes like alcohol like this
the whole experience is a bit alcohol's
like nah cuz so
i went and i was like let me read this
again organic chocolate truffles
assortment
alcohol i was looking at my wife i was
like
i just i just had alcohol
and i was like oh my gosh and then
obviously the first thing that comes to
mind is that of course you're not at
fault because
you didn't know yeah and if you don't
know you're not accountable for that
but since we're talking about alcohol
people drink alcohol but um spam i ended
up eating alcohol
it's very important for us to talk about
it because allah subhanahu wa says in
the quran it is the mother of
all evils brothers and sisters all
kinds of evils and subhanallah it's a
simple thing that is sold at the shops
like it's nothing it just means nothing
and the damage the destruction that it
causes people's lives
it's we cannot measure it from drink
drivers
killing murdering people so much so that
there's people who have literally
been in accidents where they've lost
their life their family members lives
some have been burnt because of a car
accident that happened because of
someone that was driving that was drunk
and be it the diseases that it carries
be it to your
liver your kidney your heart and all the
other things that it comes with
subhanallah we're living at times panel
that we've even put in
alcohol in food and chocolate subhan
allah so brother sisters please be
careful
um yes um and yeah i
just be very careful please bro and
sisters be very careful and read
carefully
um and yes that's what i'm going to say
and subhan allah
alhamdulillah subhanallah always tells
us um
whenever he tells us not to do something
if it's haram
we either follow what allah says or we
see the harm
in the haram for ourselves then we say
ah
i should have listened to allah let not
it be a day comes
that you see the harms in it and come to
the realization
rather be one of those who have tawakkul
in allah
trust him and abstain from it beforehand
before it harms your brothers and
sisters
and may allah protect us from these uh
truffles i'm going to set them on fire
and i might smash them into pieces a
minute yes
that's it that's what i want to share
with you guys bro and sisters please be
very careful
when you're getting these products
usually you don't tiramisu and stuff
like have it but i never knew
truffles would have them till next time
assalamu alaykum
do not forget to pray isha
goodbye